au début je ne savais pas si je vais me
prendre la wiiu et puis je me suis
souvenu de cette promesse que je m'étais
fait lorsque j'avais 11 ans quand je
serai grand je m'achèterai toutes les
consoles le jour de leur sortie
et puis bah
c'est la nouvelle console de salon de
nintendo qui a la particularité d'avoir
une manette avec un écran tactile
bon c'est vrai que jouer sur une console
de salon qui a un écran dans sa manette
au début on peut trouver ça un peu
bizarre
probablement le meilleur téléviseur du
marché seulement 31 mm d'épaisseur 116
cm de diagonale définition full hd de
1920 par 1080 pixels des images
époustouflantes tout ça pour jouer sur
un écran de 6 pouces bon et après avoir
joué à plein de juin le gamepad c'est
quand même vachement bien tu peux tu
peux faire des courses
on voyait des shurikens tout ça mais
pour l'instant on ne peut jouer qu'avec
un seul gamepad par console comme on
peut voir sur la boîte du jeu nintendo
landes
donc quand tu joues avec des potes on
peut assister à ce que j'appelle
l'hypocrisie de la wiiu
tu veux jouer la wiiu d'accord tu veux
quelle manette laisse-moi peser le pour
et le contre d'un côté une manette
totalement neuve avec un écran tactile
dessus de l'autre une manette
dégueulasse qui date de six ans non
aller à moi tout comme original comme
concept
un des joueurs à une manette différente
avec son propre écran enfin limite il
serait pas dans le même cas ce serait
pareil qua non mais allez les mecs moi
je veux non tu vas jouer dans la chambre
tu as voulu gamepad maintenant tu
assumes auquel moi je voulais juste
jouer dans la chambre et avec le sourire
s'il te plaît voilà un sort et nintendo
c'est bien le premier truc qui m'a
choqué avec cette manette basset taille
et avec ça on dirait oui c'est pour
qu'ils dominent le monsieur que la
moustache c'est parti j'espère que
nintendo va s'arrêter là 1
après le succès de la wiiu
voici la wii y j gros bras rien et en
plus de l'écran tactile
ils ont ajouté une caméra dans la
manette qui permet notamment de vous
filmer pendant que vous jouez
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu votre tête
lorsque vous jouez à un jeu vidéo
bompard ronde une fois que tu as compris
le truc pas du tout joue différemment
quoi bon la caméra sert aussi à autre
chose on peut se prendre en photo pour
faire son propre mini regarder ça c'est
mon lit j'ai trouvé une astuce pour être
deux visages
et c'est pas trop mal et pour finir ma
conclusion sur la wiiu c'est bien je
suis un mec plutôt concis dans la vire
j'aime bien quand c'est au fait vous
avez dit un truc dans mon avant dernière
vidéo
ah oui je suis une petite surprise pour
vous sur mon téléphone jeunes sortir une
application sur iphone et android
c'est pour voir mes vidéos être prévenu
lorsqu'il ya une nouvelle qui sort peu
joué avec mes vidéos et il ya le sipri g
c'est pour faire des photos comme sur
instagram mais version mois voilà dans
les grandes lignes on télécharge et là
elle est gratuite
c'est pas cher quoi à bientôt